k
[Música]
Boa noite minhas queridas meus queridos
sejam muito bem-vindos a mais uma live
de respostas à perguntas dos apoiadores
eu tô com uma situação meio inusitada
hoje tô com mais de 50 perguntas para
responder eu acredito que vai dar para
responder mais ou menos metade talvez
uns 30 um 30 perguntas
ok teve um usuário que eu não vou falar
aqui quem é para não constrangimento que
mandou sozinho mais de 30
perguntas então eu peço para vocês
quando for assim vocês dividam as
perguntas ok dividam as
perguntas Digamos que você tem 30
perguntas coloca 10 perguntas por semana
para não
monopolizar digamos assim o tempo todo
né fica mais equilibrado assim né Se for
possível né mas eu V vou tentar fazer o
meu melhor aqui boa noite Reinaldo boa
noite Eliana
renilde seja muito bem-vindos à
Live pessoal vá me dando um feedback por
favor
sobre o microfone tô sem meu
microfone headset hoje né inclusive
amanhã deve est chegando o meu
microfone de Podcast né que é melhor
ainda
Boa noite ruberg e Cristina bem Vamos
começar que tem muita coisa para falar
aqui
hoje
bem deixa eu dividir a tela com vocês
aqui
D Alan O que é artrose quais as causas
sintomas e tratamentos é possível cura
na medicina integrativa existe relação
entre artrose infarto e
AVC Ah Pera aí que tá Tá com probleminha
aqui
pera aí será que eu tô vendo de uma
pessoa só as
perguntas bem Eu tô com duas sequência
diferente de perguntas eu vou seguir uma
Outra Sequência aqui tá porque vai ficar
mais fácil para
mim ok antes de responder essa pergunta
da artrose eu vou responder a pergunta é
importante Sempre Estar atento a
ingestão de proteínas e níveis acima de
1 g kg peso meu caso no exame de sangue
ter níveis bons de proteína confirme a
gestão correta ou existem outros fatores
a
considerar vai depender muito 1 g por kg
dia para a maioria das pessoas é
adequado para algumas pessoas vai ser
mais adequado 1,5 a 2 g kil dia e os
níveis de proteína no sangue não
necessariamente refletem a ingestão
diária de
proteínas quando você mede no sangue
geralmente Você mede Albumina e
globulinas isso pode ser influenciado
por vários fatores como
hidratação função do fígado e se tem aí
doenças inflamatórias ou
infecciosas então pra gente analisar de
uma maneira mais abrangente é bom que a
gente analise além das proteínas do
sangue também a massa muscular né Por
uma
bioimpedância a recuperação muscular pós
exercícios
e a sensação de saciedade da pessoa e de
energia de modo
geral é importante avaliar também a
saúde
gastrointestinal se existe deficiências
nutricionais micronutrientes vitaminas e
minerais o equilíbrio hormonal também é
uma coisa
relevante Então tem que ser visto de uma
maneira mais abrangente próxima pergunta
o hálito cetogênico ele é
temporário ele não é necessariamente
temporário mas geralmente ele é
ok ele acontece quando a pessoa tá
comendo bastante gordura e a dieta
bastante baixa carboidrato o corpo
começa a queimar gordura para produzir
energia em forma de carboidrato isso
leva produção de copos cetônicos e um
deles é a acetona acetona que tem no
esmalte então Aliás não no esmalte mas
que tem lá no material que as mulheres
usam para aplicar depois o esmalte então
a acetona tem um cheiro muito
característico forte então por isso que
existe esse ábito de acetona em pessoas
que estão fazendo dieta
acetogênese cetogênico é temporário
porque o corpo tá se ajustando e depois
que o corpo se ajusta o odor tende a
diminuir ou desaparecer tá para
minimizar o hálito cetogênico é
interessante beber bastante água e
mastigar gomas de mascar sem açúcar para
ajudar a aumentar a produção de saliva e
neutralizar Essa questão aí da cetona Ok
e também manter obviamente uma boa
higiene bucal escovar bem os dentes
fazer bochecho aí com óleo de coco ajuda
bastante e com consumir chás herbais
como hortelã pimenta Cila isso tudo vai
ajudar a próxima pergunta na apostila
que eu disponibilizei fala no verso da
segunda página na parte de cima que é
melhor quebrar o jejum com uma bebida
desintoxicante mudar a visão
aqui tal como água em temperatura
ambiente com limão exindo na hora isso
quer dizer que que o limão quebra o
jejum e os demais chá citados
também então
na questão mais rigorosa possível
qualquer alimento que você ingira vai
quebrar o jejum só que a gente chama de
jejum metabólico quando você
Teoricamente não ingere carboidratos
você na prática apesar de ter quebrado o
jejum Você ainda está com uma quantidade
tão baixa de glicose no sistema que nem
é é considerado uma quebra real de jejum
Mas aí você pode chamar de jejum
metabólico tá então o chá sem açúcar um
óleo de cor com limão tem tão pouca
caloria que na prática Você pode falar
que isso não é quebrar o jejum
Ok ah o Renaldo tá me dando aqui o
feedback que o som tá ok e a Cristina
também beleza boa noite Estela boa noite
todos que estão
acompanhando então é uma boa ideia você
quebrar o Jeju com uma bebida
detox Porque durante o jejum o corpo vai
eliminar uma série de toxinas Então esse
detox vai ajudar nesse processo aí ao
final desse jejum Ok o limão por exemplo
tem a vitamina C que é largamente
utilizado com detox e outros
antioxidantes e beber a água com limão
vai ajudar a reidratar o corpo e
preparar o sistema digestório pro dia eh
Outro chá como caso do chá de hortelã
pimenta gengibre camomila lavanda chá
verde eles podem ser úteis para iniciar
o dia de maneira saudável chá de o chá
de gengibre por exemplo tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias e antioxidantes
Ok Dr Alan como um diabético pode evitar
a hipoglicemia quais os perigos da dieta
cetogênica para
a dieta cetogênica não é perigosa para
diabéticos tá o pessoal confunde muito
uma coisa que se chama coma de cetose
coma Ceto diabético né com a cetose
fisiológica essa questão do do coma
acetoacético ele só acontece quando o
Diabetes tá extremamente mal conduzido
ele vai ter essa situação específica aí
que ele não vai
conseguir tem uma sujeira aqui no no
monitor
aqui não tô entendendo o que que
aconteceu aqui
nesse uma sujeira na tela aqui esquisita
B vamos lá vamos continuar
aqui então para evitar
hipoglicemia é crucial manter um
controle rigoroso dos níveis de
glicose e adotar apos alimentares
saudáveis Ok então tem que verificar os
seus níveis de glicose
regularmente você tem que tá tendo uma
dieta rica em fibras frutas legumes e
integrais beber bastante
água
Ok a atividade física regular também é
muito importante suplementos como é o
caso da
berberina o Cromo e a coenzima que1 vão
ajudar então a questão da dieta
cetogênica ela vai ajudar o diabético a
não passar por aquela situação
de ficar com pico de glicose Ok
a cetogênica ela vai por ser rica em
gorduras e baixo carboidratos ela pode
levar uma redução significativa nos
lives de
glicose isso vai aumentar o risco de
hipoglicemia só se esse paciente tiver
tomando insulina
Ok algumas pessoas que asma dieta
cetogênica inadequada que ingere as
gorduras não saudáveis elas podem passar
por uma situação
de aumento do DL colesterol mas isso só
te V ingerindo muita gordura ruim
Ok próxima pergunta Dr Alan pimentão e o
tempero coloral pode na dieta cetogênica
pode o doutor disse que carne vermelha é
apenas duas vezes por semana mas o causa
da carne vermelha pode todos os
dias não não acho que pode todos os dias
não o óleo de oliva baixa a Glicemia dos
alimentos não não baixa para baixar ele
tem que ser colocado em cima dos
alimentos não não baixa a Glicemia não
faz sentido isso o que ele vai acontecer
é que o azeite de oliva vai retardar tá
vai retardar absorção
uma sujeira aqui meu monitor mas acho
que eu consegui tirar
agora então ele vai retardar a absorção
da glicose mas ele não vai tirar a
glicose dos alimentos
tá tanto pimentão quanto coloral são
baixos em carboidrato então eles podem
ser tranquilamente se adicionados a
dieta
cetogênica oo de carne vermelha eu não
usaria todos os dias porque é um
alimento processado
tá e o azeite de oliva como eu falei não
vai tirar a glicose do alimento mas ele
vai retardar absorção dos alimentos de
forma geral Isso vai ser benéfico pro
diabético
Ok ele vai modular a resposta glicêmica
Apesar dele não reduzir a quantidade de
glicos nos alimentos
o óleo de coco e o óleo de oliva podem
ser ingeridos antes de dormir prejudica
o
sono ingerir quantas horas antes de
dormir para não prejudicar o
sono o exercício físico
corrido deve ser feito quantas horas
antes de dormir prejudica o sono sim o
exercício físico se você você fizer
muito em cima da hora de dormir vai
prejudicar o sono pra maioria das
pessoas tá o óleo de coco e azeite de
oliva dão energia paraa corrida D sim
tomar antes ou depois tomar antes
Ok então o óleo de coco de modo geral
ele não vai atrapalhar o sono
Ok desde que você consuma em quantidades
moderadas pode até ajudar a melhorar a
qualidade do Sono Devido as propriedades
nutricionais
antiinflamatórias então só Tom Cuidado
para não ingerir muito próximo da hora
de dormir porque ele pode dar um
desconforto
gastrointestinal e tem um detalhe eu
falei que o óleo de coco e o azeite de
oliva eh podem ser usado antes da
corrida mas o óleo de coco ele vai ser
mais apropriado ainda antes da corrida
enquanto que o azeite de oliva ele vai
demorar mais tempo para se queimar
e ele pode ser utilizado também depois
da corrida para ajudar na recuperação
muscular na redução da inflamação porque
ele tem aqueles polifenóis né Se for um
um azeite de oliva de alta
qualidade dout Alan minha cetose deu 1,4
já é cetose terapêutica É sim se você tá
falando dos medidores comuns na apostila
fala que deve ser 0,5 até 4 milimoles
Sim é isso mesmo então se eu mantiver
essa faixa etária nessa faixa etária
quer dizer faixa cose né Eu estou em
cetose terapêutica ou recomenda ficar
acima de quanto Não acima de um Tá ótimo
já não tem porque ficar aumentando mais
ainda tá
Não há necessidade de aumentar mais aa
essa
cetose Boa noite meu pai está com dor no
braço direito não consegue mexer direito
tem problema de visão ponto de quase não
sei aí foi quase ponto né a pessoa não
terminou a frase ao conseguir ler
começou ontem a dor no braço não entendi
isso mas a visão já e há algum tempo
amanhã ele vai fazer o exame de sangue o
suspeito diabetes Nossa tá muito confusa
essa escrita aqui iniciou jejum ontem de
noite vai ficar a a hoje de noite e vai
comer um caldo de carne e após iniciar o
jejum para o exame amanhã de manhã
recomenda que ele inicie o jejum hoje de
noite que horas para exame o jejum é por
volta de 8 a 12 horas o exame é amanhã
até às 9 horas da manhã recomendo que
ele fique forçando o
braço Por que forçando o braço ou deixa
ele em repouso ele não consegue colocar
a camisa de botões sozinho ontem de
noite ele tomou água com limão e vinagre
de maçã pois no momento não tenho
beberina recomend fmin nos primeiros
dias tá bem confuso isso
aqui misturou muito coisa
aqui bem eu não vou falar quem fez a
pergunta mas quem fez a pergunta por
favor Se tiver ao vivo me ajuda a
entender
aqui o que você tá querendo com essa
pergunta aqui porque falou do exame
falou do jejum aí depois falou da dor no
braço
ah eu não tô perdido aqui não tô sabendo
responder isso não
essa questão de forçar o braço tá
falando é por causa da coleta de sangue
no braço é isso não tô entendendo isso
tô tentando entender com toda boa
[Música]
vontade e aí você deu limão e vinagre de
maçã para tentar baixar a Glicemia mais
por causa do exame é
isso não vamos lá vamos a berberina e o
vinagre de maçã vai ajudar a controlar a
glicemia
isso não tem nada a ver para a coleta de
de exame Ok isso tem que ser a médio e
longo prazo não é para só para fazer a
coleta de de de exame Laboratorial essa
dor no braço tem que ser investigada o
que que é essa dor no braço Ok visão tá
ruim pode ser problema na retina por
diabetes com certeza mas pode ser um
monte de outras coisas
também e o jejum já falei entre 8 e 12
horas de jejum para fazer coleta de
sangue essa ess história de forçar o
braço eu nem
entendi tô tentando ajudar
certo tá em rela falei de 8 a 12 horas
de
jejum começa o jejum por volta das 9
horas da noite se for fazer a coleta no
dia seguinte entre 7 e 9 horas da manhã
OK então só beba água nesse período
obviamente o braço tem que ser mantido
em repouso até que alguém avalia essa
situação que eu não sei o que tá
acontecendo com esse
braço Ok então é o que eu posso posso
fazer aqui a pergunta ficou muito
confusa D Alan tem que fazer o teste de
cetonas todos os dias ou se eu fizer
jejum e comer os mesmos alimentos não se
você fez um mês e nesse mês
consistentemente você tá entrando em
cetose não tem necessidade de você ficar
medindo o resto da vida a não ser que
você mude a sua dieta por algum motivo
Ok então não tem necessidade de passar
de um mês esse teste cetose não a não
ser que você mudou a dieta por algum
motivo é só primeiro mês para você
ajustar a dieta Tá então não tem
necessidade de ficar toda hora furando o
dedo para
isso agora mudou a rotina por algum
motivo aí é bom você medir mais algumas
vezes para garantir que você tá se
mantendo insetos
Ok
eh próxima pergunta café amargo com óleo
de coco quebra jejum e dieta cetogênica
não quebra o jejum Se for muito rigoroso
na definição quebra mas continua tendo
um jejum metabólico Ok vinagre de maçã
com limão e água quebra jejum mesma
situação tá tudo que você pô na boca que
não é água vai quebrar o jejum de um
ponto de vista muito rigoroso de
definição mas não tá quebrando o jejum
metabó ok
Castanha de Caju e Castanha do parata
lectina elas consumidas em grandes
quantidades quebram a dieta cetogênica
vi médicos recomendando ingerir apenas
uma ou duas por dia por pessoa eu Eu
consumo quase 80 G qual o perigo do
excesso de selênio e demais minerais
presentes nas castanhas não selênio vai
quebrar cetose não a castanha do Caju
queimada Faz Mal pode fazer mal
sim sim Vamos lá por partes né a
Castanha de caju e castanha do Pará tem
sim lectinas são proteínas que são
encontradas em várias plantas né então
el Tem sim e as lectinas podem ser
problemáticas para algumas pessoas mais
sensíveis comou
intolerâncias e dependendo da quantidade
que você costumi de Castanha ela pode
eventualmente quebrar a cetose porque
ela tem um certo conteúdo de carboidrato
né que em condições normais não é tão
grande se você não consumir tanto assim
quantidade Mas pode acontecer de quebrar
acetose sim
então a mais de 880 g de castanhas por
dia pode ser excessivo para uma dieta
cetogênica Então tem que medir também
para ter certeza
tá e o excesso Celene apesar de não
quebrar a cetose pode levar uma situação
chamado selenose que dá sintomas como
náuseas diarreia fadiga e problemas
neurológicos o excesso de queima da
castanha de caju pode alterar a
composição química dos nutrientes e
criar substâncias que são potencialmente
tóxicas
Ok na dúvida faz o teste tá se você
comer por exemplo 50 g de Castanha acima
de 80 não recomendo você pode estar
medindo para ver se tá tendo algum
impacto na
cetose Dr Alan o caldo de carne vermelha
que é faço não é sua receita recomendada
Mas eu só coloco osso ou carne ah o
caldo de carne que estava falando da
outra pergunta eu acho que não era o
caldo que eu tava pensando que é o caldo
de carne de cubinho né eu respondi
pensando no caldo de carne cubinho Mas
se for um caldo de carne que você fez em
casa
mesmo aí eu acho que pode ingerir todos
os dias Ok como eu falei eu tinha falado
que não mas tava pensando na forma
industrial
ada só coloco osso ou carne e ferro por
30 minutos ou um pouco mais aí eu
tempero com coloral
alho cebola roxa e às vezes cominho esse
caldo é
cetogênico olha vai depender
muito da quantidade de carne que você
colocar porque a carne tem proteína
proteína vira aminoácido aminoácido pode
virar glicose Então vai dependendo da
quantidade que você for colocar de carne
nesse caldo aí
certo tem que fazer uns testes aí
dependendo da quantidade você faz o furo
dedo vê os copos tetônicos e vê se você
conseguiu chegar no nível de cetose
usando esse caldo aí Dr lã posso beber
água antes de almoçar sim eh não tem
problema problema é tomar junto com a
refeição posso beber após o almoço Hum
Tem que esperar pelo menos uma hora para
tomar água depois do almoço tá posso
beber líquido com a comida não recomendo
o vinagre e o limão com água é melhor
consumir antes ou depois do alimento o
vinagre com limão com água é melhor você
consumir pequeno porque aí a quantidade
também não é grande você pode estar
consumindo depois do alimento Sim quanto
tempo antes ou
depois se você tomar água meia hora
antes de uma refeição tá tranquilo Se
depois de você fazer refeição é melhor
esperar uma hora para para tomar de novo
ok
então Eh eu tomaria o vinagre de maçã e
o limão um pouco depois da
refeição mas tem gente que toma também
um vinagre de maçã e
[Música]
o e o suco de limão antes da refeição
também não tá errado porque isso pode
estimular a produção de sucos gástricos
ok
B eu acho que essa pergunta já foi dout
Alan quanto mais alta acetona no sangue
mais rápido é a cura tanto da cognição
como diabetes Não não é essa questão não
é para ficar subindo aeta eternamente
porque tem um limite né como eu falei e
você colocou na outra pergunta esse
limite é por volta de 4 milimol então
não é para você ficar com uma acetose
infinita
Ok é para você manter entre 1 e 4 0,5 já
começa mas se você conseguir manter
entre um e qu é o ideal Ok pela sua
experiência pessoal como praticante da
dieta cetogênica e como médico que
atende pacientes que também faz a dieta
não eu não faço hoje em dia dieta
cetogênica já fiz no passado
tá Qual a minha
opinião já expliquei sobre essa questão
tem limite para cetose tá não tem
sentido ficar subindo a cetose mais do
que
quatro a velocidade que a pessoa entra
em cetose vai variar de pessoa para
pessoa depende da massa muscular depende
do jejum se a pessoa faz jejum ou não
depende do Sono se tá adequado de nível
de
estresse um monte de situação né nível
atividade
física então o mais importante você
ficar obsecado com os números é você
manter consistência tá da dieta ok
dout Alana dieta cetogênica pode banana
laranja pitaria ameixa banana só se for
Verde porque ela é rica em
carboidratos ela vai tirar você da
cetose A não ser que você coma no máximo
uma banana por dia mas se for banana
verde pode comer mais laranja vai tirar
da cetose ameixa se for uma ameixa
fresca não seca provavelmente não vai
tirar da cetosa agora a mecha seca que
tem a concentração de carboidrato vai
tirar sim Pitaia geralmente é baixa em
carboidratos e não tira da
cetose as frutas preferidas nesse caso é
açaí coco abacate e frutas vermelhas tá
são os preferidos o Pitaia poderia vir
aí também depois dessas frutas que eu
acabei de
falar Doutor água de coco pode na dieta
cetogênica Pode sim mas você tem que
tomar cuidado na quantidade ela é
interessante porque ela é rica em
eletrólitos é rica em potássio
[Música]
magnésio Porém você tem que levar em
consideração que uma xícara de água de
coco tem 11 g de carboidratos e pra
maioria das pessoas se você passar de 20
g de carboidrato você vai tá saindo da
faixa cetogênica vai depender da
atividade física e outros fatores mas na
maioria das pessoas acima de 20 tá da
faixa cetogênica
Então é bom você tomar no máximo aí no
máximo estourando uns 300 ml de água de
coco por dia para não sair da
cetose D Alan você disse que tem
cânceres que se alimentam de açúcar e e
outros que se alimentam de gordura
poderia por favor falar uns 10 tipos e
de que eles se alimentam por
favor tá vamos lá
então vou falar um pouquinho do efeito
warburg esse efeito warburg que o Dr L
Ribeiro já falou há muitos anos atrás só
que ele exagerou um pouco não é toda a
célula tumoral que depende do efeito
warburg então o que que é isso é o
efeito que as células tumorais a maioria
delas tendem a utilizar a glicose sem a
participação do oxigênio então é uma
glicólise anaeróbica Ok ou seja sem
oxigênio e quando você então dá para
esse paciente glicose em doses altas
pelo sangue essa glicose vai acumular
nas células tumorais vai oxidar virar
ascorbil e como a célula tumoral não tem
um sistema antioxidante decente porque a
mitocôndria tá desligada
geralmente vai matar a célula tumoral ok
porém tem várias células cancerígenas
que sim quebram ácido grassos que são
derivados de gordura Ok então essa
questão que todo o tumor só usa glicose
não é
verdade assim como tem a situação da
glutamina que pode virar também glicose
porque é um
aminoácido glicogênico né o aminoácido
pode fazer neoglicogênese e e virar
glicose
Então vamos lá câncer de mama geralmente
pode usar ácidos graxos dependendo do
subtipo ok a maior parte dos subtipos de
câncer de mama usa glicose o câncer de
próstata pode ter uma maior dependência
de ácido gracho o câncer de pulmão
Geralmente só usa glicose o câncer de
intestino grosso de Colon pode usar
também ácidos cros o câncer de fígado
geralmente usa mais glicose o câncer de
pâncreas também mais glicose o câncer de
ovário pode usar ácidos grassos e
glicose o câncer de estômago geralmente
usa só glicose o câncer de tireoide
também só glicose o Câncer de cérebro
geralmente também só glicose tá isso é
geral tá gente eu tô falando aqui muito
por cima porque também não tô levando em
consideração aqui que tem um monte de
tipos histológicos diferentes para cada
um desses órgãos tá o câncer de colo não
é só um câncer de fígado não é só um
câncer de pâncreas não é só um tem
vários subtipos Tem vários tipos
histológicos
Ok próxima pergunta independentemente do
tipo de câncer a dieta cetogênica
previne não respondi iso na pergunta
anterior né de uma maneira
indireta ela vai ser altamente favorável
de cetogênica Mas como eu expliquei tem
câncer que usam os gros então ele não
vai resolver todos os tipos de câncer
não Mas é interessante para ajudar no
tratamento da maioria dos
cânceres D Alan mesmo que uma pessoa não
faça exercício físico mas ela se
alimenta de acordo com a dieta e faz
jejum ela consegue produzir cetonas ou
tem que fazer exercício Obrigatoriamente
algumas vezes por semana tem que fazer
Obrigatoriamente
Ok só se ela não puder por algum motivo
só que ela só se ela tiver uma limitação
muito grande que ela não consegue fazer
exício físico mas é obrigatório é um dos
pilares de uma boa saúde fazer a idade
física
regular Tá mas é totalmente viável e
possível você entrar em insetos sem
atividade física só que fica muito mais
difícil
tá Carl de Bod pode na dieta cetogênica
mais de duas vezes por semana pode
ou segue o mesmo da carne vermelha em
geral Segue o mesmo da carne vermelha em
geral
Ok quando a gente fala não consumir
carne vermelho duas vezes por semana
mais de duas vezes por semana não é por
causa da cetosa porque a carne vermelha
tem suspeita sobre ela não tem nada a
ver com a questão da
cetosa isso é falado por conta da da
questão aí das aminas heterocíclicas né
que tem na carne que ainda tá sob
Suspeita Especialmente quando a carne é
bastante cozida
Ok leve pensamento na parede da bolsa
escrotal direita de natureza
inespecífica se possível uma explicação
sobre não é relevante isso daí
tá isso é Lud de ultrassom de escroto
isso não é relevante do ponto de vista
Clínico tem que ser correlacionado com o
exame físico e com sintomas do paciente
tá gente isso aqui é um tipo de pergunta
que é para tentar né já expliquei para
vocês que não é objetivo do grupo ou da
comunidade fechada de ficar discutindo
exame de paciente
tá possibilidades
tá ação do testículo
epididimite
hidrocele trauma tá bom reação
alérgica certo mais do que isso eu não
vou falar porque tem que correlacionar
todos os dados de sintomas exame físico
para chegar a uma conclusão
Ok D Alan se a gente retirar o glútem da
alimentação não corremos o risco de
ficarmos
com doença celíaca Uai De onde você
tirou
isso de jeito nenhum faz menor sentido
isso né Tá invertido aqui né a relação
causa e efeito né a doença celíaca que é
rara é menos de 1% da população que é
diferente de intolerância não celíaca ao
glúten Ok vamos falar d celí primeiro 1%
ou menos da população a pessoa não
tolera o glúten glúten inflama
tremendamente o intestino delgado essa
pessoa então o tratamento principal é
pessoa ficar longe quilômetros de
distância do glúten OK agora se a pessoa
que não é celíaca para de comer o glúten
ela nunca vai ficar celíaca não existe
isso tá o que você tá confundindo aqui é
que a pessoa que tem intolerância não
celíaca ao glúten se ficar sei lá 3S
meses sem comer glúten e voltar a comer
ela pode ter uma reação glut que ela não
teria se não não tivesse tirado da
alimentação mas aí é um fenômeno
imunológico porque toda vez que você
come um alimento te faz mal o organismo
se defende daquilo lá produzindo O gg4
que é uma subclasse de imunoglobulina g
que dá Uma segurada nas outras
imunoglobulinas para elas não atacarem
tanto a pessoa tá isso é um conceito
imunológico um pouco
complexo tá então
eh se você tem tolerância não celí ao
glúten se você você ficar muito tempo
sem comer o glúten e voltar a comer sim
você pode ter uma reação forte Mas isso
não é um sinal ruim na verdade é um
sinal bom porque você tem que ficar
mesmo longe do glúten
Ok d alão retirarmos o glúten da
alimentação existe o risco de
desenvolvermos doença cía não já
respondi isso aqui acho que a pergunta
veio
duplicada você considera a panela ginox
fundo triplo uma boa
opção elas são uma boa opção mas tem que
ver se elas não TM um revestimento né No
fundo que pode tornar elas problemáticas
Ok essa situação aí ajuda a cozinhar os
alimentos de uma forma mais
forme e pode ficar mais saudável tá o
aço em si não vai reagir quimicamente
com os alimentos Mas se por acaso
tiverem colocado algum revestimento
antiaderente Aí sim pode ser
problemático pra saúde
ok Você considera que apenas ozonizar
frutas e verduras é suficiente para
garantir higienização não você tem que
lavar e e
ozonizar né primeiro lava depois você
ozona faz as duas coisas tá E é
interessante se possível usar uma
solução de vinagre branco diluído em
água né para poder ajudar a remover
pesticida tem algumas dicas aí em vídeos
no canal sobre como retirar
pesticidas dá uma olhada depois o vídeo
um vídeo mais antigo
[Música]
tá doutor sobre a confiabilidade de uma
fá manipulação Como podemos avaliá-la o
único jeito confiável é você visitar a
farmácia e você avaliar durante um
período aí de meses ou anos o resultado
de tratamento como eu sou médico eu
consigo fazer isso para quem é paciente
é muito mais difícil né mas é viável sim
se você conhecer a farmácia e você aviou
várias receitas com eles e já visitou a
farmácia você pode como eu falo visitar
não é visitar o balcão não é visitar lá
dentro né onde é feito processamento
do dos ativos
né então se você viu lá dentro que tá
tudo em ordem e você já consumiu durante
vários meses mes e viu que tá fazendo
efeitos ativos aí você pode est
confiando nessa
farmácia outra coisa um outro detalhe se
você pedir uma informação eh paraa fç
por exemplo pedir uma avaliação
eh química por exemplo se eles não se
recusarem a fazer é um bom sinal né
dor Alan quem tem pancreatite pode fazer
dieta
cetogênica pancreatite tem cura tem
pancreatite aguda tem cura é só uma
doença grave que pode muitas vezes eh
levar para sua morte mas se você
conseguir pegar um pancrea no início ela
não for muito intensa ela tem totalmente
possibilidade de de cura né a
pancreatite aguda tem mais cura do que a
crônica crônica muitas vezes não tem o
que fazer a não ser ficar repondo as
enzimas que a pessoa perdeu e não
consegue produzir mais
tá quem tem pancreatite durante a
pancreatite você não vai fazer dieta
cetogênico agora você se recuperou da
pancreatite você pode sim fazer a dieta
cetogênica
OK agora se a pessoa tiver uma
insuficiência pancreática crônica por
conta de uma pancreatite crônica aí vai
ser bem mais difícil pessoa fazer dieta
cetogênica porque ela vai ter que tomar
muito enzima para poder compensar o
pâncreas que não tá funcionando direito
tá se uma pessoa faz o teste de cetose
de noite então é certeza que de manhã e
de tarde ela também estava de cetose não
não é certeza não tá é possível sair
cetose de manhã sim e recuperar de tarde
sim é
possível a acetose ela pode variar ao
longo do dia dependendo de vários
fatores Ok logicamente o principal delas
é dieta o nível de atividade física e o
metabolismo individual então é
totalmente possível pessoal acordar com
uma hiperglicemia reacional e no meio da
tarde entrar em cetose ou vice-versa
começar o dia com cetose no meio da
tarde sair da
acetose
Ah você disse que se uma pessoa fizer
dieta cetogênica Com o tempo ela sente
gastura de coisas muito
doce é não é bem gastura ela perde
o desejo por doces geralmente né Isso
quer dizer que a dieta muda o paladar
sim muda o
paladar é principal explicação para isso
é quando você come menos alimentos doces
o paladar fica mais sensível Então
quando você come uma coisa muito doce
chega a doer a papila gustativa tá por
isso que você muda o
paladar dout Alan Existe algum exame de
sangue capaz de descobrir
antecipadamente AVC infarto não não
existe não porque Av infarto são eventos
Agudos o que existe são exames que vão
ver o grau de ento da artéria e o risco
de ter AVC infarto mas não vai prever o
infarto ao AVC
né Lembrando que os exames s mais úteis
para verificar riscos aí de fenômenos
tromboembólicos é o dímero a proteína
ser reativa o fibrinogênio
os lipídios do sangue a Glicemia
insulina hemoglobina
[Música]
glicada OK são esses exames mais úteis e
você pode também estar
fazendo apesar de ser um exame muito
invasivo você pode fazer uma anjo
tomografia de coronária se tiver
indicação fazer isso para ver o grau de
estreitamento das artérias
coronárias e pode fazer a mesma coisa
com o cérebro né uma anjo ressonância
uma anjo tomografia cerebral Ok mas tem
que ser muito bem indicado exames que
levam radiação no caso da tomografia e
no caso da ressonância contraste também
com gadolínio né pode fazer isso à
toa D Alan O que é artrose agora voltei
na aquela pergunta que tava fora de
ordem quais as causas sintomas e
tratamento é possível cura na medicina
integrativa então artrose é um termo
genérico que significa que as
articulações desse corpo estão rígidas
Estão
inflamadas estão com perda de mobilidade
estão dolorosas Ok e ela acontece quando
a
cartilagem perdida e quando o líquido
sinovial também é perdido são né as
substâncias que geram aí a proteção às
extremidades dos Ossos então você perde
perdeu camada de cartilagem perdeu o
líquido sinovial as articulações vão se
desgastando Isso tá muito relacionado
tanto ao uso indevido dessas
articulações como a inflamação crônica
por alimentação inadequada e também pelo
uso excessivo dessa articulação
Ok e os sintomas principais de artrose
são dores nas articulações
especialmente após atividades físicas
rigidez matinal diminuição de mobilidade
inchaço ou
sensibilidade Deixa eu ver se eu
respondi toda a pergunta é possível cura
não cura não vai ter uma cura Mas vai
ter um controle tá como é que você vai
controlar com antiinflamatórios naturais
curcumina serrata com canela de
velho com unha de G
Ok gengibre tem efeito antiinflamatório
arnica também
tem você pode fazer uso de ozônio pode
fazer uso
de também o dmso que eu já falei várias
vezes tanto oral quanto local né Você
pode usar o msm pode usar o colagio
hidrolizado tipo do pode usar
glucosamina pode usar condroitina
não tem relação direta entre artrose e
infarto AVC só que essas três condições
podem ser causadas parcialmente por
inflamação crônica que é causado por uma
dieta inadequada e falta de atividade
física
Ok existe pizza
cetogênica depende do ingrediente se
tiver uma massa por exemplo de flor é
possível que ela seja cetogênica sim mas
tem que ser uma pizza muito
diferenciada e existe tão massas que são
feitas aí com couve flor
e tão com nos de macadâmia ou Farinha de
coco isso é possível então você criar
uma pizza cetogênica só que são
pouquíssimas pizzarias que trabalham com
esse tipo de material
Dr Alan conhece site livros e receitas
sobre como fazer bolos low carb tem um
monte aí de livro de receita sobre isso
tem um monte é só você procurar na
Amazon você vai achar um monte
eu inclusive tenho alguns aqui no meu
computador que eu passo para pacientes
né geralmente quando você quer fazer
bolo larb você vai usar farinha de nozes
de castanhas no lugar de farinha de
trigo você vai usar também Farinha de
coco você vai utilizar estévia você vai
utilizar aulos imo como a ou w Fruit
você vai utilizar ovos né então Eh e
frutas de baixo índice glicémia
Ok fiz uma pergunta sobre meu pai com
braço e movimentar na sua opinião Pode
ser avc ou infarto não sei como é que eu
vou saber
desculpe pode ser tanta coisa porque o
braço não tá movimentando Pode ser avc
pode pode ser infarto infarto não porque
infarto não dá
problema motor né geralmente AVC mas
pode ser um problema no braço em si né
problema neurológico no nervo do braço
problema muscular difícil né o médico
diz que acha que é artrose ou pode ser
diabetes
alto pode ser tanta coisa
aí tem ser analisado pelo médico como eu
falei para vocês aqui não é o objetivo
de fazer diagnóstico
não eu sei que eu posso parecer
antipático falando isso mas e essa que é
a questão o grupo não é para fazer
diagnóstico de caso específico e nem é
apropriado porque vocês sempre vão
passar menos informação do que
eu precisaria e mesmo que desse todas as
informações seria antiético eu tá
analisando isso aqui
n a farinha de amas É cetogênica sim é
de depend da quantidade se não
ultrapassar demais Vai ser sim qual a
melhor Farinha do ponto de vista de
médico integrativo já falamos sobre isso
agora a pouco né não vou me repetir tá
se for o caso
você volta no ponto de novo farinha de
nozes e castanhas farinha de amêndoa
Farinha de coco farinha de semente de
chia são essas opções aí que são mais
loucar ok
Dr Alan manter-se hidratada é
fundamental para a dieta cetogênica sim
é fundamental a pouca ingestão de água
afeta o processo cetose sim
afeta a água é muito importante pro
metabolismo se você ingerir pouca água
você vai reduzir a eficiência do
metabolismo e a capacidade do corpo de
en cetose
Ok e também fic muito ligado nos
eletrólitos nos minerais né
especialmente o
magnésio o potássio e o sódio porque no
começo da dieta cetogênica é comum você
perder esses eletrodos junto com a água
quando você vai eliminando o
glicogênio Dr Alan quantas vezes eu devo
medir na minha cetose por
dia eu sugiro que você meça duas vezes
por dia se for possível tá de manhã e no
meio da
tarde outro dia também você pode
alternar num dia você mede de manhã cedo
e no meio da tarde outro dia você mede
de manhã cedo e à noite antes de dormir
você tem uma informação de diferentes
horários tá
se uma pessoa suspeitar que pode ter AVC
com uma semana de antecedência ela se
hidratar pode
evitar como é que você vai suspeitar que
você vai ter um AVC uma semana depois
não faz menor sentido isso
né você tem que estar bem hidratado
tempo todo né mas você não vai conseguir
prever uma semana antes que você vai ter
AVC né só se você for o volta
mercado você for Paranormal né senão
você não vai conseguir prever
isso porque se você já tá com sintoma
né Por exemplo formigamento ou fraqueza
numa parte do corpo já tá tendo já
praticamente um AVC ser um ataque
isquêmico transitório né um pravc mas
não tem como você prever uma semana
antes
vai at
AVC dout Lana na base inicial da dieta
cetogênica pode dar esquecimento e
problemas de
sono é se você tiver naquela situação da
Ket oflu né que é gripe
cetogênica e tiver desidratado por
exemplo você pode ter esquecimento sim
tá disturbio de
sono por isso que é importante tá muito
bem hidratado e tá ingerindo o sal
integral e outros minerais para evitar
essa
situação D Alan a dieta cetogênica cura
ou faz entrar em remissão depressão TDH
esquizofrenia não não cura a depressão
pode ajudar bastante porque vai
desinflamar o cérebro mas curar eu não
posso dizer que cura talvez alguns casos
muito específicos mas de modo geral não
mesma coisa pode ajudar muito o TDH Mas
provavelmente não vai curar
esquizofrenia com certeza não vai curar
né
a de cetogênica vai ser uma ferramenta
para todas essas doenças aí mas não vai
curar nenhuma delas a tem casos muito
especiais quando nos
escova
os Não entendi eh eh quando escova os
dentes deve ser isso limpamos a boca
várias vezes com água fica um gosto
gosto de
refresco minha pergunta esse gosto
quebra acetos não não
quebra quebra
não só que você não deve engolir a pasta
de dente né porque aí Se tiver açúcar na
pasta de dente aí você sai da cetose
ok dout
o trabalho braçal serve como exercício
físico e a caminhada que fazemos quando
vamos ao centro da cidade a
pé sim lógico
serve pois nem uma notícia exício físico
para ser produtivo a pessoa tem que
estar pensando em realmente fazer
exercício não aí ela vai ser mais eficaz
o exercício você tá fazendo de uma
maneira mais consciente né Óbvio mas não
quer dizer que andar na rua para ir no
mercado por exemplo
ou fazer trabalho braçal não seja
atividade física é
sim D Alan muitas das receitas da
Postila que você pediu para traduzir usa
um queijo feta não é feto não queijo
feta que é um queijo de cabra Tá mas o
queijo inflamatório o queijo de cabra
Não é ele é casina na A2 tá Aliás ele é
ele é mais antiinflamatório
tá Dr Alan Você conhece alguma pessoa do
seu ciclo social que faz bolo Fitness
que você possa indicar Mesmo que não
seja
cetogênico vi tem pacientes meu que
fazem às vezes eles até vendem mas que
seja confiável e talvez até compartilhe
receitas gente eu falei esse negócio de
receita não é o bicho do outro mundo é
só vocês procurarem no no Amazon ou em
livraria online vocês acham isso gente
não é difícil não
entendeu outra coisa tem muita conta no
Instagram e no Facebook mesmo no YouTube
que compartilha essas receitas aí de de
bolo Fitness tem canais especializado
nisso em receitas fitness Isso não é
um ciência de foguete um bicho Sete
Cabeças
não vai na Amazon e pega uns livrinhos
lá se você pagar aquele
Amazon aquele tem
uma eu esqueci o nome lá Do mas tem um
programa da Amazon que você paga uma
mensalidade lá lá de R 20 Eles te dão
acesso a vários livros gratuitos Eu já
vi vários desses livros serem de receita
ou carb ou ou sem glúten ou cetogênico
tá isso não é uma coisa difícil gente
não é
mesmo diabetes pode causar
artrose sim pode por que ocorre
amputações e
cegueira por causa que a diabetes vai
destruindo as
artérias da retina causando segu
e e também dos pés que leva amputação
porque aí vai destruindo a artéria vai
dando úlcera vai dando necrose aí tem
que amputar entendeu Porque também tem
uma infecção por cima
OK então a questão do diabetes além dele
vai destruindo as artérias periféricas
as as finas ele também vai gerando
neuropatia diabética que vai causando
falta de sensibilidade e às vezes pode
causar dor neuropática
também Quais exames para saber se tem
diabetes e seus níveis normais e
diabético e resistência
insulina Eu já falei isso tantos vídeos
anteriores
né glicemia de jejun tem que tá abaixo
de 90 a insulina de jejun tem que tá tá
abaixo de 10 hemoglobina glicada tem que
tá abaixo de
5,3
Ok Esses são os
números mas já foi falado em vários
vídeos anteriores isso
daí o diabético mesmo vai ser
glicemia acima de 120 de jejum vai ser a
insulina é acima de 30 e a glicada acima
de 6,3
Tá mas isso daí eu não recomendo você
esperar ficar diabético né você vai
querer ficar com os níveis ideais que eu
falei
agora você po indicar probiótico de F
mais
completo então tem
o 20 B né que é
interessante e eu comprei também um
probiótico muito bom
recentemente que é o
o cara me deu um branco agora esse que
você compra farmácia comum né você fala
de farmácia mais competa a tá querendo
dizer de farmácia comum e não
manipulação
[Música]
né cara me fugiu o nome desses
probiótico mas tem um que eu comprei
recentemente inclusive para mim que eu
gostei muito
dele Pera aí que eu vou olhar isso agora
aqui ver se eu acho aqui para passar com
mais precisão
aqui T tendo lembrar o nome me deu um
branco agora
a biota 25 B eu vou escrever aqui
na biota 25 b
pronto tá bom eu coloquei aqui
na conversa
aqui assisti o seu vídeo de salão como
se livrar do
antinutriente se Vou picar em Oxalato
minhas mãos Milion Costa muito sals tem
um antinutriente da mesma família se eu
fizer somente o chá dele vou perder
muitos
nutrientes bem para você retirar o
salato de alimento é o cozimento tá você
vai fazer o cozimento Os Vegetais isso
vai tirar a maior parte dos
antinutrientes
cozinhando o iame você vai tirar o
Oxalato outra maneira de você tirar
fermentando é muito interessante porque
os microorganismos vão tirando os
antinutrientes também ralar e picar e
deixar descansar por um tempo ajuda a
ativar enzimas que quebram esses
antinutrientes tá então ralar e picar
ajuda
muito e o chá de sal eu acho que é uma
boa ideia tá que o processo de
infusão vai ajudar a tirar os
antinutrientes
e vai manter a maioria dos nutrientes
benéficos
Ok e para minimizar a perda de
nutrientes do do salsão quando você usa
na falma de
chá folhas frescas ou
secas não aqueça a água demais porque
pode perder então destruir alguns
nutrientes e deixa as folhas infundindo
por cerca de 5 a 10 minutos não deixa
mais do que isso ok
dieta cetogênica cura Alzheimer sozinho
não cura mas ajuda demais auda muito na
na condução da doença el é extremamente
importante para tratar o Alzheimer
apesar de não ser exclusivamente isso
que vai curar os ok
dout Alan conhece alguma Confeitaria low
carb Olha se fosse você não ia para
confeitaria nenhuma viu is é
fria euo vai achar uma Confeitaria LC
você vai achar a confeitaria que diz que
não tem glúten que diz que é fit n não
sei o que lá mas realmente LC muito
complicado tá
eu acho que mais fácil você achar uma
pessoa que
faz a so demanda esses doces locares aí
tá agora uma Confeitaria eu não conheço
confeitaria de verdade assim existe
algumas padarias LC né Confeitaria é
diferente né padaria tem agora
Confeitaria não conheço
ISO dout Alan Qual é o adoçante mais
saudável atualmente Dr la Ribeiro disse
em vídeo que o simples gosto do açúcar
na boca já pode causar diabetes não não
ass não entendeu gosto de açúcar na boca
não causa diabetes nunca tá o que
acontece que o gosto de açúcar na boca
pode ativar insulina já a liberação de
insulina que não é tão interessante pro
organismo mas não vai causar
diabetes Eu acho que o melhor de todos é
o Stevia puro
tá melhor AD Sante o segundo colocado
seria o Monk
frut drout Alan qual sua opinião sobre
goma chantana o que que é o goma
chantana é um polímero natural que é
derivado da bactéria hormonas campestres
ele é utilizado como espessante
emulsificante e muitos produtos
alimentícios e também
cosméticos eu nunca li nada falando
muito mal de goma chantana mas ela pode
causar efeitos colaterais
gastrointestinais algumas pessoas pode
gerar gases pode gerar flatulência
Diarreia dor abdominal por causa das
bactérias que vão
degradar
essa goma Ok e algumas pessoas podem ter
Alergia ou intolerância à goma chantana
também D Alan Qual é o melhor substituto
da massa de trigo já falamos sobre isso
né gente tá se repetindo as perguntas
aqui
né Vamos usar as Farinhas de
oleaginosas né farinha de amêndoa já
falei aqui farinha de quinua farinha de
linhaça Paria de chia
né Você pode est tá usando a biomassa de
banana
também
ok
ah tá ontem a 17 horas postei lá no
grupo uma tabela de magnésio do Dr
Fernando Bastos caso não tenha visto não
vi sim
eh tá perguntando se endosso os dados
que o magnésio de malato por 500 mg de
suplemento vai ter 75 mg o treonato 144
glicinato 72 o citrato 80 taurato 75
cloreto 60 lactato 84 e o óxido 20 sim
eu endosso só que não é só ver quanto
que tem de magnésio elementar em cada
tipo de magnésio quelado tá isso é uma
informação interessante sim
ah somente que não é só a quantidade é a
quantidade que vai ser absorvida tá
então a glicina ela vai ter uma taxa
absorção geralmente mais alta do que os
outros mesmo tendo menos MG de magnésio
elementar por 500 mg de suplemento
tá e de fato o óxido de magnésio é o
menos absorvido pelo corpo a absorção é
cerca de 4 a 12% não é 1% só
tá E é muito utilizado como laxativo n
não para repor magnésio em si Ok para
repor Lógico que é muito melhor o
glicina o dimalato treonato o taurato
são bem melhores para absorção
tá e a dose excelente é de entre 200 e
400 mg por dia do mineral alimentar tá
essa que é a dose considerada excelente
Depende de pessoa para pessoa vai ter
que fazer a conta já que você tem a
tabela aí fazer a conta do em relação
elementar a quantidade de
suplemento a empresa nutrimentos foi
vendida para empresa
nlab suo intimate performance mudou o
nome para
performance além de mudar o nome eles
fizer algumas mudanas n
sues mudança foi para melhor você também
acha que a mudança foi para melhor ou
para pior não sei el tô por dentro Deal
tá vou ficar te devendo
essa resposta porque não não fui
analisar Exatamente esse essa empresa aí
que tá falando não posso depois ler com
calma esse link que você colocou aqui tá
D Alan minha cetose 6,4 estou em cetose
Lógico né acima de de 0,6 eu tá em
cetose mas eu nem nem recomendo manter
isso daí 0,5 A4 Vamos colocar aí
redondar de um a qu acima de quatro já
não é recomendado não
tá cara Dr Alan se minha sincera
desculpa de não ter lido os termos das
perguntas gostaria muito ser membro você
já é membro Fica
tranquilo o senhor disponibilizou uma
fórmula anticâncer de próstata para
membros quais os ativos senhor
acrescentaria a fórmula para desinchar
vários deles lá já desincham
tá de um paciente assintomático com uma
leve alteração de tamanho se precisar de
mais informações sem alterações
hormonais com libido boa ereção matinal
e no sexo outra pergunta uma vez a ota
ascendente com moderada dilatação e com
pequena placa de ateroma tem como
regredir para o tamanho normal ou pelo
menos permanecer estacionada a dilatação
dilatação não vai regredir não a placa
se você tomar suplemento por do a 3 anos
pode regredir sim natoquinase picnogenol
tá você tá juntando tanta informação na
mesma pergunta aqui pressão arterial
normal
despideme basal de 36º tireoide dentro
valores ó ótimos de
referência tá vamos lá eh os principais
suplementos para reduzir a próstata que
estão naquela fórmula é o sal palmeto
pigon africano Tiga de oica o extrato de
pólen de trigo também é muito bom para
próstata licopeno vai ser o efeito
câncer tá fora os minerais
zinco
Magnésio e as vitaminas como cas da
vitamina D tá paraa placa de aorta seria
natoquinase picnogenol principais tá
vitamina C vai ajudar bastante né que
ajuda na saúde endotelial o enzima q10
ajuda na ajuda Resveratrol ajuda
tá para aumentar a temperatura corporal
é interessante você fazer mais atividade
física ganhar massa muscular suplementar
iodo a ch Ganda pode ajudar na tireoide
além de ser uma planta adaptogênico
que eu terminei todas as perguntas deixa
eu ver se tem mais aqui eu eu nem sei
como conseguir responder tanta pergunta
hoje me deem só um instante aqui
tem mais uma pergunta aqui só deixa eu
ver a
pergunta se a cetose está acima de
quatro pode fazer mal uma pessoa que a
cetose chegou à seis ela é doente por
chegar tão alto e tão pouco tempo três
dias Não é para ter cetose acima de
quatro já expliquei Isso numa pergunta
anterior tá por favor faz nas loves deve
ser lives né aquela lista debaixo dos
vídeos sobre cada pergunta não eu não
vou fazer mais não tá
eh tendo mais de 60 perguntas aqui fica
meio difícil para mim
tá você disse coco ia sair qual parte do
coco bagaço Branco a copra que é o a
parte parte branca do do coco tá pode
ser consumido à vontade e o açaí tem que
ser ele natural então não pode ser ele o
vendido em lojas e açaí não tem que ser
açaí sem açúcar
tá dout Alan então uma pessoa antes de
fazer dieta cetogênica deve fazer exames
para saber se tem
predisposição a todos os tipos de
cânceres não não sei se tirou
isso não a dieta cetogênica não vai
aumentar o risco de câncer tá o que eu
falei é que tem cânceres que consomem o
ácido graxo Então não é que a dieta
patogênica vai curar a pessoa do câncer
é isso que eu expliquei você tá fazendo
uma confusão aqui
tá não tem nada a ver você não tem que
fazer teste para saber se tem câncer
para começar a dieta cetogênica porque a
dieta cetogênica não aumenta o risco de
câncer tá a pancreatite ela pode ser
silenciosa só a crônica não é silenciosa
tá essa variação de cetose e não cetose
durante o dia quebra o tratamento não
não quebra
não não quebra não
bem pessoal Já são quase 9 horas da
noite eu vou encerrar a Live
tá eu não tô mais apresentando as
perguntas do formulário Eliseu porque a
sequência tava fora de ordem para mim
aqui tá
depois vocês podem estar vendo o resumo
das lives lá no documento
tá eu não vou conseguir responder as
perguntas ao vivo pessoal já estamos
quase 9 horas da noite tá olha aqui a
dica da da Estela Mares
sim quem toma K2 pode tomar l Tu quein
tá é Estela Bem lembrado aqui tá temos 1
hora E20 de Live porque hoje teve mais
de 60 perguntas eu não consegui falar de
artigo né Eu acho que tá meio exagerado
esse negócio das perguntas aqui estel a
gente vai ter que rever isso tá
bem vou encerrar por aqui
porque passamos de 1 H20 eu tô dando uma
olhada se tem alguma pergunta
mais interessante aqui ao vivo
sim eu tava falando L do técnico sim
você pode pedir uma avaliação química de
os princípios que você tá utilizando a
fassa se eles não recusarem é um sinal
de que a a fassa de
qualidade bem pessoal realmente a a
Estela tá colocando um ponto aqui muito
importante né a gente tem que
tem algumas perguntas mal formuladas e
aqui eu não tô fazendo Nenhuma crítica a
ninguém especial Tá mas o pessoal tá
digitando as perguntas eu acho sem tá
dando uma revisada primeiro na
ortografia ou na pontuação ou tá revendo
exatamente o que tá querendo perguntar
tem algumas perguntas que estão juntando
muita coisa na mesma pergunta tá ficando
confuso de entender o que que a pessoa
quer com aquela
pergunta de novo não é uma crítica não
quero deixar ninguém aqui em situação
difícil tá de de tá se expondo mas
realmente a gente vai ter que tá dando
uma reavaliada nisso né Porque do mesmo
jeito tem pessoas aqui que querem que
ter as suas perguntas respondidas tem
outras que querem que a gente discuta
ciência né de de qualidade aqui
né E aí eu fico respondendo às vezes
perguntas de alguns
membros aqui do grupo que gostam de
fazer quantidades muito grandes de
perguntas e deixo de est respondendo a
demanda de outros membros que querem tá
tendo acesso a esses artigos né que eu
vou tá explicando numa linguagem mais
simples de entender para vocês né então
a gente tem que fazer uma escolha aqui
ou a gente vai ficar respondendo dezenas
e dezenas de perguntas de algumas poucas
pessoas ou a gente vai
procurar ser mais democrático e
tá respondendo a demanda de da maioria
das pessoas aqui tá Isso é uma coisa
para vocês refletirem eu não vou me
recusar a responder pergunta porque eu
acho chato isso mas eu acho que a gente
tem que começar a ter um pouquinho mais
de bom
senso primeiro pensar antes de fazer a
pergunta para não ficar repetitiva a
pergunta né e ficar às vezes só mudando
um detalhe na pergunta e fazendo a mes
pergunta de novo um detalhezinho a mais
ou a menos e ficar uma coisa repetitiva
e às vezes não é uma coisa produtivo
para a maioria das pessoas que estão
acompanhando as lives né depois quem que
vai ter paciência de ficar Assistindo um
vídeo de 1 hora
me0 né com monte de pergunta às vezes
fora de contexto
né ótima sugestão Tá eu vou fazer o
seguinte gente eu eu vou colocar um
limite de 10 perguntas mas se eu fizer
isso também sabe o que vai acontecer vai
ter gente que vai colocar cinco
perguntas numa mesma pergunta como já
até aconteceu hoje né colocaram teve uma
pergunta lá que tinha cinco ou seis
perguntas na mesma pergunta e ficou até
confuso de responder porque tava tudo
embolado
né Mas vamos tentar colocar essa regra
de 10 perguntas por pessoa Ok se eu
identificar que a pergunta Tá muito
confusa e e tem muita pergunta junta na
mesma pergunta vamos dizer assim eu vou
responder só uma pergunta das cinco ou
seis que tá agregada ali ok ok pessoal
então eu vou colocar isso lá no na
descrição do WhatsApp são 10 perguntas
por pessoa por Live tá no
máximo Então
Ah eu vou ficar te devendo o artigo tá
Estela mas semana que vem eu vou vou
fazer o seguinte eu vou fazer muito mais
sobre artigos e muito menos sobre
perguntas tá bom paraa gente poder
equilibrar as coisas aqui boa noite para
vocês um grande abraço beijo no coração